So the first one is obviously correct.
So far, we have not found a polynomial time algorithm for the three problems here.
We've shown in the last unit that they are practically relevant or at least
slightly simplified versions of highly relevant problems.
All of the simple problems go through an exponential number of solutions.
That's what made all of those simple algorithm so bad and their running time--
all led to the exponential running time, but the thing is going through that exponential
number of 0-1 assignments is also what made those problems hard to solve.
If you have given a certain assignment, checking if that is valid and how large it is--
for example, if it's better than a solution you have found so far--that is relatively easy.
It's doable in polynomial time.
Now, the answers to this quiz might seem rather obvious to you
and you might be wondering what we're going to do with those answers,
but I promise you it will all make sense very soon.